[Music]
with election hacking under
investigation and the threat of more
hacking to come there may be a lot to
learn at a convention underway in Las
Vegas Def Con 25 marks a quarter century
of bringing together computer hackers
from around the world this year they've
been given a challenge to break into
voting machines similar to the ones used
in the 2016 election for more on this
we're joined by John Biggs editor at
large for TechCrunch John good morning
honey
so an annual conference what's the usual
goal here what are they trying to
accomplish
usually the usual goal is to experiment
so one of the coolest things that they
do is a it's called the badge contest I
guess you could call it and everybody
has a special badge that's actually
electronic so everybody has to work
together to figure out what these badges
do and there's a series of puzzles
inside of these things
so the real ethos there is hacking it's
building cool stuff taking apart stuff
to see how it works and in figuring
things out just on the fly so they've
the organizers have issued a challenge
to try to break into voting machines is
that legal
it is actually legal so there used to be
a challenge against it according the
Daeva DMCA which is a it's against
intellectual property cakung all this
other good stuff but they found in 2015
that if you do it for a good cause if
you do it and for research specifically
you're allowed to do it these are
hackers and not to make them all look
bad not of all all them are great guys
so why trust them dude sorry - the
hackers out there look I mean you got it
you got a bunch of it submitted I've
gone there a couple times and I identify
as a nerd got a bunch of nerds going to
a thing to try to do a bunch of cool
stuff and it's so there's so there's
black hat hackers white hat hackers I
would argue the vast majority if you're
going to Def Con you're not you're not
sitting you're not sitting in some
darkened room trying to hack into a bank
you're basically working for a bank and
you're wanting to learn the
state-of-the-art essentially okay more
trustworthy in that regard
that sounds giving them better for the
Deaf how difficult is it to hack into
voting machines well look you got a it's
like a it's like a clamshell and you
have to crack that thing open first and
then you have to figure out what's going
on on the inside and if you think about
the way they have to manage these things
the
only the only time you get with a voting
machine in the real world is about two
minutes inside of inside of a school gym
somewhere so what they'd have to figure
out is how to figure out how to hack
that thing through all that security in
about two minutes which is massively
difficult and is the idea then that the
government can use this information to
make us more protected ideally but the
problem is the voting machine folks they
like to do security security through
obfuscation security through hiding so
they'll say look you can't even touch
these things because if you do then
you're gonna figure out these secret
things that we have put in place and
that really doesn't work you really have
to open these things up and you have to
share them with researchers who could
actually figure out how these things
actually work is there is there what
needs to be done to secure voting
machines to secure voting machines they
have to be completely open you have to
essentially give one to these DEF CON
every year and say here try to break
this thing open and as soon as they
break it open somebody from the voting
machine company should be sitting there
and saying okay we didn't see that we
didn't see that right and then you have
if you have more eyes makes things mix
up bigger problems easier my apologies
to the white hat hackers black hat guys
don't come after me John Biggs thank you
Thanks